I grew up on a beef farm in Missouri and
like everybody else at raises livestock
we raise a lot of our own feed to stay
in business and we raise corn and
soybeans and hay and we grind this stuff
up into a flour and we'd add vitamins
and minerals and trace minerals make
pellets and you feed those calves for
about six nine months and then you ship
them off to be butchered or maybe two
other feeders and you always say back
the very best ones for yourself and you
knock him in the head Needham it's a
real simple cycle on the farm and the
thing that fascinated me as a teenager
was that we went to a great deal of
trouble for those calves and yet as a
family we ate out of the very same
fields we'd keep back five rows of corn
for ourself we had a garden at the end
of the field where we grew our peas and
beans and squash and tomatoes and we
wanted to live to be a hundred with no
aches and pains and we didn't give
ourselves the very same vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals that we gave
the calves and always used to ask my dad
he'd say hey pops how come we go to all
that trouble for those calves and not
for ourselves and he'd say shut up boy
getting farm-fresh food fresh air lots
of free exercise don't ask complicated
questions and I was glad to get rid of
the farm exercise and go to AG school at
the University of Missouri and there my
major was an animal husbandry and
nutrition my minor was in field crops
and soils and I began to learn technical
things about soil chemistry and how
related to tonnes and bushels per acre
and AG economics but I didn't get an
answer to my basic question until I
became a freshman veterinary student at
the University of Missouri and there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals and animal feeds bottom line is
because we don't have insurance for them
we don't have Blue Cross Blue Shield
major medical consolation Medicare
Medicaid and if we were to use a human
health care type of system for animals
it'd be sticker shock for you your
hamburger would cost you two hundred and
seventy five dollars a pound boneless
skinless chicken breast be four hundred
fifty bucks a pound dozen eggs be fifty
dollars just to pay for the healthcare
so we learned that we could keep the
price of animal products such as meat
and dairy and poultry and eggs down to
where the average American could afford
them simply by significantly reducing or
totally eliminating healthcare cost and
we do that in animals by preventing and
curing diseases with nutrition well
after graduating vet school I went to
Africa for a cup
years and got to work with Marlin
Perkins from the old Mutual of Omaha
Wild Kingdom days that was kind of a
kick got to play Frank buck to use a
tranquilizer gun Tromp all over central
in South Africa for a couple of years
and then Marlon sent me a telegram and
invited me back to the States he'd
gotten a seven and a half million dollar
grant from the National Institutes of
Health and this was more than 30 years
ago and this was the study pollution and
ecology in the environment and my job is
the wildlife veterinarian on the project
was to do autopsies of animals who died
of natural causes in the big zoos around
the United States and I was supposed to
identify or find a species of animals it
was ultra sensitive to pollution and
we're going to use that animal much like
the old coal miners used to use Canaries
you know how that goes i take the canary
down in the mine and if methane gas or
carbon monoxide were to leak in the mine
the Canaries were more sensitive than
the men and would drop off the persian
diam long before the men were in danger
of suffocating or blowing up well to
make a long story short after some 12
plus years of working on this project
and done some 17,500 autopsies and over
four hundred and fifty four species of
animals plus three thousand human beings
for a comparison and what I learned was
that every animal and human being who
dies of natural causes dies of a
nutritional deficiency disease and I got
kind of excited about nutrition again
and I wrote 75 scientific papers on the
subject wrote chapters four eight
multi-author textbooks actually
contributed a textbook myself a thousand
pages two thousand illustrations and
through the news releases that run the
big universities I worked with I was on
20/20 was in 1,700 newspapers around the
world through the UPI and ap news wire
services and with all this public
exposure and with all the scientific
exposure I couldn't get people who are
in a position of authority either in
medical research or in politics to get
to concerned or interested in preventing
and curing diseases and human beings
with nutrition just like we did in
animals well I got frustrated enough I
went back to school in Portland Oregon
became a physician and I practiced there
for 12 years as a general family
practitioner and I sewed up chainsaw
wounds delivered babies used everything
that I learned in veterinary nutrition
of my human patients and it was no
surprise to me that it worked just as
well in people as it did in
well to get started I always like to
talk about longevity and the human being
has the genetic potential to live
healthily to be a hundred and twenty I'm
going to prove that to you in just a
minute
unfortunately Americans do a lousy job
when it comes to longevity our average
lifespan in the United States is seventy
five point five about half or
genetically capable of in 1990 when the
World Health Organization examined the
top thirty two industrialized nations on
earth the United States came out 17th
there's actually 16 other countries
whose peoples live longer than we do we
ranked 19th and healthfulness that meant
that there were 18 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do before
they develop heart disease and cancer
and diabetes and arthritis and
osteoporosis we ranked 23rd when it came
to live birth and first years survived
abilities of babies and we ranked dead
last 32 out of 32 when it came to
preventing birth defects now what all
this means is we have the highest price
health care system in the world
but not the best it also means that we
have the most envied health care system
in the world but not the best we have
the most technologically advanced health
care system in the world but not the
best well I had a good friend by the
name of Christopher Byrd for many many
years over 20 years in Chris I was a
best-selling author on books on our
ganglia growing food he was an expert in
this subject and I was always trying to
give him vitamins and minerals and he
refused to take them and he'd tell me
doc I bring my own cooler I don't eat
any hotel food I bring my own
organically grown food and so I don't
need to take vitamins and minerals well
I was changing planes again in Atlanta
had an hour to kill picked up the local
newspaper and guess whose obituaries
found in the newspaper Chris Byrd rose
again he was a best-selling author of
books the secret life of plants the
secrets of the soil and he died at age
68 from a ruptured aneurysm a type of
stroke seven and a half years before the
average American dies and he led a
pristine life lived up in the mountains
had an organically grown garden
collected herbs you know like Euell
Gibbons and ate wild hickory nuts and
all those kind of things and because of
his belief he died of a copper
deficiency and I'll show you in a minute
that copper deficiency causes a ruptured
aneurysms and it's just a tragic thing
that people have so much to give and die
at less than half their genetic
potential for longevity a lot of people
say to me doc I don't need to take
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
because I use herbs now herbs are not
new
trician you have to understand that
herbs are not nutrition they are great
plant medicines they're safer they're
more economical in most cases are more
effective than prescription medications
that doctors will give you but they're
plant medicines if you have diarrhea
they can tighten you up if you have
constipation they loosen you up if you
have hypertension or high blood pressure
and bring it down if you have a fever
and bring it down but don't expect to
get enough calcium or selenium or boron
or copper or vitamin A from herbs well
I've been doing biomedical research and
clinical research and animals and human
beings and I can tell you no matter how
you look at health and longevity whether
it be in animals or human beings there's
only really two concepts you have to
deal with concept number one I refer to
as avoid stepping on the landmines this
is where you don't want to throw away
your healthy physical body wastefully
you don't want to smoke don't abuse
alcohol don't do drugs don't jog down
the highway at two o'clock in the
morning wearing an all-black ninja suit
you're gonna get hit by a truck mirror
right whenever a doctor says here's our
options never say doc whatever you say
you're the you're the doctor when a
doctor says here's our options what you
want to do is say look I want copies of
all these records and tests and want
copies of the x-rays and go visit three
other doctors and three other hospitals
you want to talk to 12 of their living
patients that had gone through this
procedure talk to him see if you really
want to do this I mean you do this for
your driveway and your roof and your
fence in your yard and all that kind of
stuff why not for your own physical body
that's concept number one now that
you've avoided the landmines you're in a
good position to do all the positive
things that you need to do to go on to
live to be over 100 basically what you
want to do is take all in essential
nutrients 60 that's six Oh minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids and
three essential fatty acids they're
called essential nutrients for two
reasons number one your body cannot
manufacture them you must consume these
every day there is food or supplements
number two if any one of these essential
nutrients is missing for a couple of
months a couple of years you get on the
average ten deficiency diseases you have
everything to gain doesn't lose by
supplementing properly well the medical
profession of course has this malignant
dumb belief that you can get everything
you need from your four food groups
my favorite article of all time in the
press was April 6 1992 Time magazine
cover article the real power of vitamins
new research shows it may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
aging six positive pages if you haven't
read it I'd urge you to go to a public
library school library to dig it out and
read it
there was only one negative sentence and
as you might guess it was offered by a
medical doctor who was actually
contacted by the writer of the article
said what do you think about vitamins
and minerals and and trace minerals as
supplements for human nutrition here's
what he said quote popping vitamins
doesn't do any good sniffs dr. Victor
Herbert a professor of medicine at New
York City's Mount Sinai Medical School
we get all the vitamins we need in our
diets and taking supplements just gives
you expensive urine unquote
now Missouri translation of that is
you're just peeing away your money you
might as well a lot up your dollars
throwing a toilet and flush them away
you can get everything you need from
your four food groups is what he's
trying to say well I'd rather pee out 50
cents for a dollar day worth of excess
vitamins and minerals that's cheap
insurance think about it how much money
to spend for coffee or soft drinks or
newspapers and that kind of stuff every
day fifty cents to a dollar day to
maintain and repair your body and it's
kind of fascinating that most people
don't do it just remember will you pay
that doctor out of your own pocket or
indirectly through insurance or
indirectly through taxes and Medicare
Medicaid not a single penny of that goes
to better understand manage treat
prevent or cure catastrophic diseases
and kids breast cancer and women
prostate cancer and men now a lot of
people ask me why did you call your
original tape dead doctors don't lie
well that's because I believe for a long
time because I had done medical research
for over 20 years in large medical
research institutes medical schools the
various laboratories and I always had a
belief in the medical system but I was
very disappointed when I learned that
doctors don't know the most about health
and longevity doctors don't know the
most about disease they do know about
procedures you know how to fix your
bones when you break them and that sort
of thing how to do a cat scan and so I
began to look in the medical journals
and sure enough the first article ever
published on health and longevity of
American doctors is published in JAMA in
June 15th 1895 a little over a hundred
years ago they said at that time doctors
lived to be fifty four point six I redid
the study 97 years later using the same
obituaries that they did in JAMA this
was January 20th 1993 in that particular
issue of JAMA and it turned out the
doctors lived to be 57.6 I rounded up
258 to give him the benefit of the doubt
and doctors just went berserk when I
said that I mean this was the most
outrageous thing they've ever heard my
principle is my premise is that doctors
don't live as long as
average couch potato in America and I
purposely put that figure out there 58
to try and challenge people well doctors
immediately looked at all the insurance
actuarial charts they got two hundred
fifty thousand dead doctors he said your
groups too small so they looked at 250
thousand dead doctors they say doctors
don't live to be 58 they died 62 they
still don't live to be seventy five
point five like the average couch potato
we actually reran this again using the
entire obituary history for 1996 and for
the entire 1996 of all the doctors dying
in 1996 with all the medical treatments
and drugs and procedures and everything
and transplants doctors and in that
study lived to be 70 still five and a
half years short of the average couch
potato in America so they still have
never proven that doctors live as long
as everybody else that's why dead
doctors don't live now if you do
everything right how old can you live to
be is it worth all the effort I believe
it is here's one Christian Mortensen
from San Rafael California in August of
1995 turned 113 August 4 1996 he turned
114 he's still going strong
certainly can live to be a hundred and
fifteen smokes a couple of cigars a day
like George Burns who also live to be
over a hundred certainly was a guess the
only exercise George Burns ever did was
put the cigars in his mouth this gal
here dora rama 'they become South Africa
and July of 1995 turned 114 and when she
was asked by the media Dora what do you
attribute your health and longevity to
she did not say that we owe it all to
our annual physical or our HMO she said
I ate locust every day you know a little
grasshopper she's not a vegetarian she's
little animals pumpkin seeds tortoise
meat wild herbs dried fruit and starts
each day with a cup of coffee this gal
here Margaret Skeets from Radford
Virginia in 1994 was the oldest
documented living American when she died
at age 115 fell over and fractured her
hip three weeks later she was dead from
complications of osteoporosis a simple
calcium deficiency and we'll talk more
about this in a minute unfortunately
this is not unusual 75 percent of all
Americans over the age of 65 who
fracture a hipper major leg bone don't
live 90 days they die of pneumonia
pulmonary embolism stroke and other
complications that fracture Susie
Brunson according to her family in
December of 1994 was the oldest American
when she died at age 123 and they based
their claim on her birthday
December 25th 1870 which was recorded in
the family Bible in this fellow here
Francisco bearson wave at chopped Arena
October 1995 he was from a little town
outside of Bogota Colombia turned 125
when he was asked by the media of
Francisco what do you attribute your
health and longevity to he said well I
drink a gallon of goat's milk every day
also is kind of fascinating in his
birthday announcement this is not an
obituaries this is a birthday
announcement said that over 40 years ago
his physicians told him he only had a
couple of months to live so he had his
sons building a coffin and he's been
waking up every morning for more than 40
years sitting by that coffin waiting to
die good night time comes he goes to bed
wakes up the next morning since by the
coffin waits to die now he's still going
strong and all the doctors who told him
that more than 40 years ago or a long
since dead now this fellow here how
moody al Abdullah from Syria died aged
133 and he was still fathering children
after the age of 100 he remarried for
the fourth time when he was aged 80
fathered four boys five girls nine
children after the age of 80 with the
same wife and we add up the pregnancies
in the breastfeeding the time in between
pregnancies he was still fathering
children after the age of a hundred now
this very next one is my very very
favorite this gal mazuma dusty from iran
according to the rocky mountain news
wire services out of Denver and the
Iranian news agency this was January of
1995 she died at age 161 now you have to
give a certain amount of credibility to
this obituary report that she died at
age 161 because she has survived by six
living children ranging in age from 120
to 128 they hadn't even left home to go
to college yet
now her oldest son golem said his mother
had never visited a doctrine are taking
any chemical medications during her life
did take a few herbs so if you kind of
think about it every one of these people
who live to be over a hundred 120 130
160 these people are not from United
States or Canada or Germany or England
kind of interesting isn't it they're
most of them are from third world
countries they're farthest away from
medical help and they lived the old so
that we're beginning to collect
information here the last one we want to
look at the National Geographic Society
a very respected group of people
scientists and and so forth and support
groups for science comes out with a
monthly magazine the National Geographic
magazine of course and they in January
of 1973 came out with a nifty special
issue on longevity they looked at
cultures whose people live the 120 and
they documented the oldest living human
being that they could find based on
their criteria this fella by the name of
Sher Ali mismo law from Azerbaijan a
little country just south of Russian
Georgia in western Russia today they
documented him as being 167 years old
remember this is the National Geographic
Society not the National Enquirer 167
years of age they had a half page
picture of him actually harvesting tea
leaves in a tea plantation still working
eight hours a day six days a week when
he's 167 five months later May of 1973
Sher Ali mismo loft earns one hundred
and sixty eight goes out and hosed the
garden for reporters to show how
vigorous he is now for at least fifteen
maybe seventy years medical doctors in
America have been pooh-poohing the idea
that you can live well beyond 100 you
know people who lived 115 120 they were
one in six billion it wasn't something
that everybody could look forward to and
anybody who tried to teach people how to
live to be 110 120 hundred 40 were
considered charlatans and quacks and
taking advantage of older people I was
glad to see this come out this was a
news article in the USA Today newspaper
in October of 2000 and it was based on a
article in the journal Science very
respectable journal and what they said
was forget a hundred try living past 120
humans possess a maximum life expectancy
longer than 120 years which had been the
long theorized medical limit in fact
lifespans appeared to be increasing over
time with no end in sight
now the key part of this is
now that there's no doubt about it
everybody agrees that human beings
including Americans have the genetic
capacity to live well beyond 120 the
doctors want to take credit for the
things that have actually increased our
longevity from 45 average lifespan in
eighteen ninety five to seventy five
point five today which is an increase of
about thirty and a half years our sewers
and good clean water Public Health
things we don't have cholera and
leptospirosis and tuberculosis and our
food supply and or water supply anymore
we have meat inspection we have public
water works and things have sewers these
are the things that have extended our
lifespan then there's this salt thing
you know whether you believe it or not
this medical dogma has really caused a
lot of problems in America how many have
ever heard that using the salt shaker is
bad you're gonna get hypertension right
you're gonna get heart disease and
stroke what's the first thing in a good
farmer puts out for his livestock a salt
blocker salt lake in it
there's nobody out in the pasture
telling a cow she's limited to one lick
a day
I refuse to believe that my human
patients are dumber than a cow say look
go ahead and pick up a salt shaker
you're gonna see the lightning won't
strike you you can go ahead and salt
your food to tasting salt your body
nothing bad is going to happen and 98%
of my patients love it they bring me
hundreds of new patients every month who
want to use salt and not to feel guilty
about it when two percent the bean
counters they see in a wallet we love
you respect you we have this high priced
cardiologist that says you're flying in
the face of all the way to medical
evidence you can't tell people that they
can use a salt shaker because you're
gonna kill them with high blood pressure
and heart disease and stroke and I've
been vindicated in this belief this was
actually a study that was published in
the New York Times
May 22nd 1996 and this study was
abstracted from JAMA the Journal of the
American Medical Association the most
prestigious medical journal in the world
according to themselves now in this
particular Journal a dr. Alexander
Gordon Logan who's an epidemiologist and
cardiologist on the teaching staff of
the medical school at the University of
Toronto up in Canada and he took 56
existing studies on hypertension or high
blood pressure and restriction of salt
combined the data from these 56 studies
which included 3,500 and five people he
threw away all the conclusions and
reevaluated the larger group and what he
found out was this if you have normal
blood pressure and your restrict salt it
will not prevent you from getting heart
disease or high blood pressure if you
have hypertension or high blood pressure
and restrict salt 97% of those with high
blood pressure or hypertension who
restrict salt will not get any
measurable benefit 97% will not get any
measurable benefit 0 to to 5% get
measurable benefit but it's not
significant they're only able to reduce
their blood pressure by 3.7 millimeters
of mercury so here's what dr. Alexander
Gordon Logan said in JAMA may 22nd 1996
he said you might as well go ahead and
salt your food to taste it's a
meaningless exercise don't get paranoid
about salt it has nothing to do with
blood pressure problems there has never
been one single iota of proof that
restricting salt has any benefit it's
just one of those medical myths he
called it but I'm gonna call it a
medical Kaka now if it's not salt what
causes high blood pressure well it's not
salt first of all because salt is an
essential nutrient there's a combination
of sodium and chloride both of which you
need and
according to the American Heart
Association the minimum daily
requirement for 150 pound person for
assault each day is a heaping teaspoon
six to nine grams of salt a day now the
Japanese who live longer than we do the
Japanese who live 4.1 years longer than
we do and have half the cancer rate they
eat 12 grams of salt a day they three
times assault we do and they live four
years longer have half the
cardiovascular disease rate and half the
cancer rate we do and yet they eat three
times as much salt as we do so you're
beginning to put the puzzle together
that doctors really don't know what
they're talking about
that's why dead doctors don't lie well
if it's not the salt and if it's not
genetic what is it well it's actually
just a simple mineral deficiency raise
your hand you ever heard that
cholesterol is bad and you got to get it
low in your blood you got to have a low
cholesterol diet otherwise you're gonna
get heart disease right
doctors would like to blame all
cardiovascular disease on cholesterol
we've known for 75 years an animal
industry their cholesterol is not a
bogeyman there's not a single disease
it's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol triglycerides you can find
me one I'll give you a million dollars
in small bills in any offshore account
you want there's not a single disease
it's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol triglycerides elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides you're
really just a warning signal much like a
fever
fevers don't cause infections but when
you have an infection with a bacteria a
virus of fungus maybe a parasite
you can get a fever you can have a
broken leg and get a fever you have
cancer and get a fever you have liver
disease and get a fever babies get a
fever when they teeth and so you have to
kind of sort it out when somebody comes
into a doctor's office with a fever you
have to say well okay here's my whole
list called a differential diagnosis all
the things cause fever if they're 80
years old you can quickly rule out
teething right but the rest of you may
have to do some lab tests for any rate
the same thing is true for elevated
blood cholesterol and triglycerides when
you have elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides it might mean that you
have hypothyroidism or low functioning
thyroid gland
you could have diabetes you can have
deficiencies of niacin and chromium
vanadium the essential fatty acids you
can have liver disease all kinds of
reasons why you might have elevated
blood cholesterol triglycerides
but then themselves don't cause any
problems now the Eskimos above the
Arctic Circle have a traditional diet
does 98 percent red meat and blubber
they will meet whale blubber walrus meet
walrus blubber seal meat seal blubber
bear meat bear fat there's not a single
Eskimo above the Arctic Circle it has a
mr. juice man juicer eats our gainfully
grown broccoli
their average cholesterol ranges from
250 to 350 and yet they're legendary for
not getting cardiovascular disease until
they come down to the lower 48 and eat
like us then when they get the
cardiovascular disease they go back home
to die up above the Arctic Circle they
start eating whale blubber again it goes
away well learning all that I felt very
confident in telling my patients look
we're gonna do something different my
goal as a physician is to have my
patients die at an average age of 100 I
don't want my patients down at seventy
five point five I don't want to give
them another 25 years I want the average
lifespan for my patients to be a hundred
and we're gonna do something different
if you want to do everything that all
the other doctors and patients are doing
I want you to go to them because I don't
want you to lower my average right we're
gonna do something different it's just
real simple my favorite disease is
arthritis I love arthritis the reason
why I love arthritis is it's easy to fix
and when you can fix something is
horrible and as debilitating as painful
as expensive and as miserable as
arthritis you get kind of excited about
this concept of preventing and curing
diseases with nutrition and so I tell
people about this arthritis thing all
the time so let's have a quick look at
arthritis number one 75 to 80% of all
Americans over the age of 50 get
arthritis to one degree or one type or
another and according to the CDC the
Center for Disease Control 35 to 50
million baby boomers are going to get
arthritis in the next seven to ten years
and there's not a single medical
treatment design to prevent or fix it
aspirin certainly doesn't fix arthritis
caused the gastric bleeding in death
tylenol doesn't fix arthritis causes
50,000 cases of kidney failure each year
5,000 which are so severe you need a
kidney transplant then there is IV profe
and advil and Aleve these things don't
fix arthritis and they cause liver
disease and 2 to 5 percent of the users
including liver cirrhosis even if you
don't drink
and then there's methotrexate and gold
shots these things don't fix arthritis
they subdue your bone marrow so you
can't make normal platelets and white
blood cells and then you have the
granddaddy's of all the medical
treatments for arthritis prednisone and
cortisone they don't fix arthritis they
subdue your immune system which leaves
you open to disease is far far more
horrible than arthritis and
prednisone and cortisone accelerate the
loss of minerals from your bones
something you don't want when you have
osteoporosis and arthritis now when
these prescription medications and
over-the-counter medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and inflammation
the only thing left for you medically is
joint replacement surgery and I never
like to send my patients in for the
joint replacement surgery because they
never work out well in fact many times
you're worse off after the surgery than
you were before the surgery the
advantage my patients have always had is
that I'm a veterinarian as well as
physician and so I always usually tell
my patients look we have all these
nutritional formulas designed to prevent
and cure diseases and animals including
arthritis and so I tried adapting
nutritional arthritis formula is
designed to prevent and cure arthritis
and pigeons and turkeys dogs cats sheeps
pigs horses cows lions tigers and bears
to human use there was no surprise to me
it works just as well in humans as a
dozen animals because it was designed to
prevent and cure arthritis and pigs and
I literally seen tens of thousands of
people who have had a regrowth of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone foundation bone matrix
doesn't matter if they're 20 30 40 50 60
70 80 90 I've seen people 97 years old
regrow cartilage and bone even if they
had bone to bone arthritis if there's
blood supply to that joint and that bone
they will regrow bone and cartilage
well of course Harvard Medical School
goes berserk when you say stuff like
that well like you can't say those
things the only thing left for people
when they get bone to bone arthritis is
joint replacement surgery and I'd agree
with them if the only raw materials are
using is tylenol and aspirin and pennons
own cortisone we've learned over 50
years that you can't regrow cartilage
and bone using those things one of the
basic things of course that the Harvard
Medical School jumped on to and they
said this is so ridiculous that this
couldn't work and so they took 29
patients arthritis patients who had
failed to respond in any way to heroic
medical treatment for arthritis over 15
to 20 years they took him off all her
medication wasn't working for him anyway
lined him up for joint replacement
surgery they said look for 90 days
before we do the surgery they gave him a
heaping tablespoonful of ground-up
chicken cartilage and there are G's
every morning for 90 days they were sort
of chuckling in their beer saying
nothing's going to happen well here's
what happened in 10 days these people
these 29 people had complete relief of
pain inflammation something they hadn't
had in 15 to 20 years in 30 days they
can now open up a new pickle jar that
never been opened without paying to the
fingers wrists elbows and shoulders in
90 days 28
the 29 were clinically cured now this is
from Harvard Medical School in the
Boston VA that meant that they had
complete return to the range of motion
all the pain inflammation was gone
and their fingers and toes and hips and
knees and her neck and certainly many of
them still had knots on their fingers
because there's only 90 days and you
think they'd call me up these professors
you know of medicine from Harvard
Medical School and from the Boston VA
and say look wallet we have to apologize
to you we've been bad-mouthing you for
20 years and once you come up to Boston
let's talk about the whole thing here's
what they said quote after three months
it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote chicken cartilage had
become a drug in ninety days now why
would that happen well because you can't
patent chicken cartilage and they
convinced that the US Patent Office that
they were using a drug to do this study
and they actually got a use patent on
chicken cartilage and you too for thirty
five hundred bucks a month can get
Harvard Medical School's chicken college
in a capsule for arthritis
of course cartilage has chondroitin
sulfate in it glucosamine sulfate
collagen these are all the basic raw
materials to rebuild cartilage and bone
raise your hand if you know what the red
warning lives for on the dashboard of a
car truck back before we had dials
showing temperatures and things that
used to use the red warning light right
it was called the idiot light and when
that red warning light came on
it meant that your engine was heating up
you didn't have enough coolant or oil or
maybe a broken fan belt or a splitter
radiator hose and a reasonable person
would would pull the vehicle car truck
over the side of the road and deal with
the problem so you didn't burn the
engine dump even a Vienna Mercedes would
burn up if you didn't have enough
coolant and oil and a fan belt and
radiator hose then of course the village
idiot that's what they called the
village idiot light or the idiot light
they'd be driving along they see that
red warning light come on and said I
don't have time to deal with this so
they whip out their flowers they cut the
wire the red warning light they keep on
driving even a Mercedes will burn up if
it doesn't have oil coolant a fan belt
and Raider hose right and so you really
have to be the village idiot to do that
nobody in the right mind would do that
to their vehicle how many of you know
what paint is for our raise your hand if
you know what pain is far that's pretty
good most of you know that paint is the
red warning light for your body when you
get pain in your foot your ankle or your
leg your knee your hip your back your
shoulders elbows wrists and fingers your
body saying don't use those joints don't
use those bones don't use those muscles
until you fix them
it's absolutely criminal absolutely
criminal for it
doctor to write you a prescription for a
pain reliever an anti-inflammatory or
muscle relaxant or any of those
combinations without rebuilding the
bones and the joints in the cartilage at
the same time if they just give you a
pain reliever just give you an
anti-inflammatory and are a muscle
relaxant without rebuilding the joints
and the bones at the same time all
they're doing is cutting the wire the
red warning light you're gonna wear
those bones and joints and cartilage out
faster and faster and faster it's
actually a negative to be taking
painkillers and anti-inflammatories
without rebuilding the joints and the
bones at the same time the reason why I
say no carbonated drinks and have been
doing that since 1964 is because
carbonated drinks actually will
neutralize your stomach acid and you
cannot efficiently absorb minerals
digest protein or absorb bottom b12
without stomach acid you have to have
stomach acid like battery acid doctors
have the criminal belief that you don't
need stomach acid they give you all
these drugs to get rid of your stomach
acid antacids and they give you drugs
and stop producing stomach acid right
they don't want you to have stomach acid
absolutely criminal you can't digest
food and absorb food without stomach
cancer I know most of you knew that
carbonated drinks neutralize stomach
acid if you remember back 25 50 75 years
ago when somebody would ask their
doctors say look I just ate it I overate
I overate a Thanksgiving dinner and I
have heartburn and indigestion what do I
do that was before they had zantac they
say well take some 7up drink some ginger
ale drink some club soda take take some
sparkling water because the carbonation
will neutralize your stomach acid and
give you some relief and it would now if
you do that three times a year drink a
carbonated drink three times a year for
Thanksgiving and Christmas and Easter
because you overeat during those holiday
that's okay you're gonna survive when
you're drinking 2 3 4 5 6 8 10
carbonated drinks a day you're not going
to survive because over the long haul
you will not be able to absorb the
nutrients you're going to get some
horrible combination of terrible
diseases this came out june of 2000 and
this is a harvard study on 460 junior
high school girls in 9th and 10th grade
and what they found out was that those
junior high school girls who drank one
non cola carbonated drink every day they
increased their risk of fractures nastya
process as a teenager by 307
they found out that if they drank one
carbonated Cola drink a cola carbonated
every day they increase the risk of
fractures and osteoporosis is a teenager
by 500% now do you think that this is
more dangerous for teenagers or adults
there's much more dangerous for adults
because you only have 25% bone matrix so
you're very very slow to recover where
teenagers have 40% bone matrix and they
can recover in a week's time we learned
in 1957 from a turkey study where they
took 250,000 turkeys and they put them
on a complete turkey pellet trying to
get them to finish for market within a
few days or a week or so of each other
and in the first 13 weeks fully half of
125,000 of them died farmers were out
there every morning they picked him up
every morning by the bushel basket Fuld
took him to the state diagnostic lab to
see what they died from when they opened
him up every one of them had died of a
ruptured aortic aneurysm and one of the
clever pathologist says that's got to be
due to a copper deficiency because
copper is required to manufacture the
elastic fibers of arteries and skin and
other tissues and the mechanism of an
aneurysm is identical to the mechanism
of a balloon on a weakened wall of a
tire you know when you hit a chuckhole
with your tire and you break the cords
the internal pressure blows a balloon
you overload that tire with weight or
heat it up on a highway it blows out
same way with an aneurysm when you have
a copper deficiency you get a breakdown
in elastic fibers in that artery the
internal pressure even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon in that
artery and a balloon in an artery is
called an aneurysm and of course if it's
in a strategic place like the brain cryo
artery the coronary arteries the large
arteries ar2 pulmonary artery renal
arteries they blow out you die suddenly
just like you've been shot well now they
got excited about this they doubled the
amount of copper in these pellets the
next year they tried to raise 500,000
turkeys and they did not lose a single
one from a ruptured aneurysm they went
from a 50% loss to a 0% loss just by
adding a little bit of copper to those
pellets so they said well maybe the same
thing is true for humans and in 1958
they started looking at a copper
deficiency in various species of animals
and humans and here's what they found
out the very first symptom of copper
deficiency is white gray and silver hair
copper is required as a cofactor to
manufacture hair pigment doesn't matter
if it's blonde Red brown or black hair
and I see a lot of copper deficiency in
this room I can almost tell you which
people men and women who have colored
their hair get pretty good at that being
a physician and you don't want to be
like a medical doctor and just treat the
symptoms if you're just
coloring your hair you're treating the
symptoms you need to do the basic thing
take some colloidal copper and if you
don't what's going to happen is you get
a breakdown the elastic fibers in your
skin and you start getting crow's feet
around the corners of your eyes in your
mouth parts of your Anatomy begin to Sag
and you know you're in trouble when your
doctor tells you look I've got a golf
buddy down the hall who's a plastic
surgeon for $10,000 I'll make you look
20 years younger but you don't need a
facelift at bubi lived a tummy tuck or a
derriere lift all you need is some
copper and everything will come back up
just like you have a hydraulic jack
under it'll just come right back up
those elastic fibers tighten right up
people say Francine did you get a
facelift you look great you looked like
you're 20 years younger if you don't
take some action at that point the next
thing that happens is you got to break
down the elastic fibers and large veins
of your legs you get varicose veins you
don't take action at that point you get
a breakdown of the elastic fibers and
large veins of your exhaust pipe and you
get hemorrhoids so if you have
hemorrhoids varicose veins things that
sag wrinkles white gray or silver here
the odds already have aneurysms
developing in you somewhere and you
don't want to of course died suddenly of
a ruptured aneurysm when your body's
been warning you for 10 20 30 years just
remember people don't die suddenly of an
aneurysm it may be you drop and die
think about old Albert Einstein he died
of a ruptured aortic aneurysm at 68
years of age what color was his hair he
was famous for wild white hair wasn't it
now you'd like to think the people who
win the Nobel Prize in medicine but at
least lived to be seventy five point
five but they lived to be 58 just like
other doctors and of course that's
because they are trained and they
believe and they practice you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups doesn't matter if they win the
Nobel Prize or not this guy here dr.
George Kohler was the youngest person
ever to win the Nobel Prize in medicine
in history 37 years old wins a Nobel
Prize in medicine and he won the Nobel
Prize in medicine for studying
monoclonal antibodies which are
antibodies trained to attack cancer
cells if they ever get this really
working it'll be great because they
won't have to use chemotherapy anymore
which kills more people and saves 11
years after winning the Nobel Prize in
medicine dr. George Kohler now 48
drops dead of a cardiomyopathy a heart
attack because he believed you can get
everything you need from your for food
rich doesn't take any selenium died of a
cardiomyopathy heart attack I have to
tell you why athletes our early warning
system couch potatoes by definition are
people who go to extraordinary efforts
not to sweat right they make every human
effort not just what
they're changing the TV channels honey
bring in the popcorn I'm changing the
channels son bring me the TV Guide I'm
changing the channels by contrast
athletes have the attitude no pain no
gain and they're out there sweating and
working away power training strength
training running and they sweat athletes
no matter H they sweat more in five
years in couch potatoes doing 70 years
and when you sweat you don't just sweat
out potassium and Gatorade you sweat out
all sixty essential minerals if you
sweat out all of your selenium and don't
replace it by supplementation or a
higher risk of getting a cardiomyopathy
heart attack you sweat out all of your
copper and don't replace my
supplementation you're high risk of
developing an aneurysm and dying your
sudden leave a ruptured aneurysm is what
I all of your chromium and vanadium and
don't replace my supplementation higher
risk of getting diabetes and if you
sweat out all of your calcium and
magnesium and boron and zinc and sulfur
and other minerals are required for
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone you're gonna get a joint and
bone injury what is the biggest single
cause of an athlete's career being ended
early joint and bone problems right and
that's because they sweat out all the
basic minerals that they need to
maintain those parts that our body they
don't supplement with them because
doctors tell them that they get
everything they need biting or four food
groups well what are the early warning
system for mineral deficiencies we
already told you about white gray or
silver here for a comprar deficiency
liver spots are age spots in the back of
your hand side of your face or neck
these things are caused by a selenium
deficiency and you know again about
selenium deficiency then of course you
have toe cramp Slade cramps so you have
hypertension these things are all caused
by a deficiency of calcium and if you're
an athlete at age 25 or 15 and you get a
leg cramp as a calcium deficiency your
body's telling you if you don't stop
drinking those Pepsi's and start
supplementing with some calcium by the
time you're 40 50 60 years old you're
going to have arthritis and osteoporosis
but most people say oh I got to get this
high-priced trainer I need somebody who
can give me the massage therapy because
I have a cramp and they don't go and
take their supplements 85% of the total
mineral in your body is a calcium
there's 147 different diseases you can
get from a calcium deficiency we're just
going to quickly go over the top ten
when it comes to a number of people
affected and the amount of money
involved let's look at osteoporosis the
number 10 killer of
United States remember 75% of the those
over age 65 who fracture a hip or major
leg bone don't live 90 days also is the
most horrible disease when it comes to
human misery and dollars expended
osteoporosis think of these special vans
and the lift gates in the ramps and the
elevators the special plumbing in homes
and and public buildings special parking
places wheelchairs and walkers and canes
think of the beds and the chairs they're
little electric motors that lift you up
when you can't stand up by yourself
physical therapists joint replacement
surgeries pharmaceuticals doctors visits
we're talking billions and billions of
dollars for nothing more than a calcium
deficiency disease
now as horrible as a disease as
osteoporosis is in human beings we don't
have osteoporosis and animals because we
don't have BlueCross BlueShield major
medical hassel ization Medicare and
Medicaid to pay for nonsensical surgical
treatments for mineral deficiency we've
learned that by putting animals who are
weaned off their mother's milk on
calcium as soon as they're weaned they
won't get arthritis and osteoporosis
it's amazing how that works
receding gums dentists and dental
hygienist will tell you to floss and
brush after every meal if you believe
that works I have some oceanfront
property in Montana to sell ya if you
have receding gums periodontal
Ginja Vitus pyuria loose teeth bridges
and plates you actually have
osteoporosis of the facial bones and the
jaw bones we don't get receding gums and
animals even though they don't floss or
brush that's because we've taken care of
the osteoporosis problem and animals
arthritis 85% of all arthritis is called
wear-and-tear arthritis osteoarthritis
degenerative arthritis ankylosing
spondylitis these things are nothing
more than osteoporosis of the joint ends
of the bones hypertension high blood
pressure as you learn has nothing to do
with salt our salt restriction 85% of
hypertension not related to kidney
disease which is most of them not
related to kidney disease is in fact a
calcium deficiency insomnia is not a
deficiency of sleeping pills
Halcyon or barbiturates it's a
deficiency of calcium kidney stones bone
spurs heel spurs and calcium deposits
again the medical profession has a
malignant dumb belief that these things
are due to too much calcium your diet
try to give up calcium when in fact you
only get kidney stones bone spurs heel
spurs and calcium deposits when you have
raging osteoporosis you actually need
more calcium more magnesium
not less cramps and twitches
raise your hand how many you've ever had
a toe cramp foot cramp leg cramp in your
life sure that's the first symptom of a
calcium deficiency that most people
recognize so if you ever had that
sometime in your life you've had a
calcium deficiency then you have PMS the
University of California at San Diego
came out and said that 85% of the
emotional and physical stuff of PMS can
be relieved eliminated and cured they
use the Cure word by taking three times
the RDA of calcium low back pain has
nothing to do with disk problems I know
you've heard of people maybe even
yourself have had a dis surgery for back
pain and after the surgery you still had
the pain maybe even worse because back
pain is not caused by disk problems if
you have a disc problem you can have
numbness and tingling maybe even
paralysis it was very severe
but disk problems do not cause pain we
learned in 1957 and animals that we
could prevent and cure adult onset
diabeetus with 2 trace minerals chromium
and vanadium 1985 the medical school at
the University of Vancouver British
Columbia in Canada came out and said the
trace mineral vanadium alone could
replace insulin and add all onset
diabetics sized a dog food has 40
minerals in it always has chromium
vanadium lithium and selenium ralston
purina laboratory rat pellets has 28
minerals always contains chromium
vanadium lithium and selenium
I'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new 100 bill if you can find me a human
infant formula off the shelf of a
grocery store that has more than 12
minerals in it none of them can contain
chromium vanadium or lithium only one
pro so well to actually pros OB and
Enfamil I believe has 12 because they
put in the selenium the rest of them
don't they have 11 10 9 or 8 minerals
our dogs get 40 minerals our rats get 28
and our kids get 12 or less you don't
have to be a research scientist to
realize why our kids are now getting all
these horrible diseases that used to
occur in people in their 60s 70s and 80s
all these diseases that doctors are
wondering how does this genetic these
kids shouldn't have this tiller 60 well
that's because they couldn't get it out
of their little can of stuff if it's not
in a can they don't get it again we need
nutrients 16 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids 3 essential fatty
acids and fortunately over the thousands
of years that human beings have been
around we haven't had to think much
about this because our food plants our
grains vegetables fruits and nuts take
carbon dioxide out of the air and
manufacture
long carbon chains many of which are
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids and
this is where this medical Kaka came
from that you can get everything you
need from your four food groups because
they say well plants grains fruit
specials and us can manufacture vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids but we've
tried this experiment for 200 years
Americans have eaten better than anybody
else in the world we've had the best
quality food in the world over anybody
else and yet we only live to be seventy
five point five we don't set any health
and longevity records so if you want to
live to be over 100 can't get it from
eating your four food groups you can
live to be seventy five point five you
may live ten years older ten years
younger but on the average seventy five
point five so if you want to live to be
over 100 you do have to supplement with
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids
there's three types of minerals you have
to concern yourself with first of all
there's metallic minerals these are
things like oyster shell eggshell
limestone coral calcium sea bed minerals
clays various types
tums is a popular one with doctors
lactates gluconate sit traits oxides
sulfates carbonates these are nothing
but ground up rocks we're not designed
to eat ground up rocks nobody can show
you where humans or animals are designed
to eat ground up rocks
we're designed to get our minerals by
eating plants grains vegetables fruits
and nuts and as a result plant derived
minerals are durable more absorbable
than chelated more absorbable than the
elemental or metallic minerals plant
derived minerals are liquid they're very
small particle size there's 7,000 times
smaller than a red blood cell this is
the way they're stored in your cells and
are moved around in plant vascular
systems and human vascular systems in
the liquid plant derived farm they're
negatively charged I don't know all of
the physics and the chemistry is one of
the basic features of a colloidal
mineral it's negatively charged these
three factors together give you absorb
ability now the way it's supposed to be
is our food plants our grains vegetables
fruits and nuts take the elemental or
metallic minerals out of the soil
convert them to minerals for their own
use for their own metabolism and
biochemistry and then animals and people
eat these plants that are enriched with
minerals that's how we're designed to
get our minerals unfortunately we have
several problems here for a hundred
years
we've used a simple fertilizer known as
NPK we put in three nutrients into the
soil when we need sixty minerals we put
those three nutrients in the soil four
maximum yields per ton and bushel per
acre then of course we have to
understand the plants cannot manufacture
minerals if they're not in the soil
they're not in the plants plants only
have minerals in them if they're in the
soil plants cannot manufacture minerals
or 90 years at least we've been
deficient in our soils in America and as
a result our food is efficient and as a
result the crops their grains fruits
vegetables and nuts that are grown there
are merely deficient and as a result the
animals and people who eat these
mentally deficient crops get mineral
deficiency diseases and the only way to
prevent and cure them is with mineral
supplements
[Applause]
yes I'm a construction worker and I hurt
my back he said that my cartilage damage
is permanent is there anything that can
be done first of all how old are you I'm
28 years old and what do you normally
take for fluid replacement we were
working out in construction what do you
drink during the day water gatorade you
don't drink any soft drinks yes I do
okay cuz normally construction workers
drink a couple of liters of Pepsi a day
right yeah I can probably put down a
leader program and did you take any
vitamins or minerals that we were
working a construction just recently
started when you're in construction
prior to the back problems yeah a lot of
construction workers will tell me well
doc if it aint and the Pepsi I don't get
it right and so you're a perfect
candidate for the pig arthritis formula
plus the EFA you need all 90 essential
nutrients and give up the bad things
give up the soft drinks and the iced tea
and the lemonade's and and you up the
fried foods and the margins and I can
just tell you with your age you can
honestly expect to see some really
recognizable results in a very very
short time 60 to 90 days and it doesn't
matter what the doctor said if you do
the right things get rid of the bad
stuff take all 90 essential nutrients
making sure you get that collagen and
the glucosamine sulfate in the
chondroitin sulfate you will repair your
vertebrae you will repair the cartilage
and you will repair the discs dr.
Wallach just seems like every week I
pick up a newspaper and I see about our
young athletes having problems with
their bodies falling apart what can we
give our athletes and our children so
that they can be healthy and have long
lives that we want as well that's a
great question because most people
believe that exercise is good for you
and that was always a great question you
know it is exercise good for you is it
necessary for health and longevity and
when you inspect this question you have
to look at professional athletes who
spend most of their teenage years and
going through university in the semi
pros and the pros training and
practicing and doing their events and
and if exercise was the factor and
living a long healthy life athlete
should live longer than couch potatoes
but when you look at this critically
couch potatoes in America lived to be
seventy five point five
and the average athlete depending on the
sport and their level of competence
lived to be 62 to 68 far short of what a
couch potato lives to be and of course
athletes suffer from a great many joint
diseases and bone injuries and tendons
and ligaments back neck shoulders ankles
knees and hips and they have to suffer
through an enormous amount of surgeries
to deal with this and athletes developed
some 800 different diseases and what is
it why is it that athletes don't fare as
well as the couch potato was simply
because athletes sweat more in five
years than couch potatoes do in 75 years
and when you sweat you're not just
sweating out Gatorade you're sweating
out all 60 essential minerals and
they're called essential minerals
because if they're missing for any
length of time you get some horrible
degenerative disease many of which are
life-threatening so you don't have to be
a rocket scientist to figure out who's
more likely to be debilitated or even
die of these these life-threatening
diseases an athlete who sweats out
quarts of sweat during an event or
training or practice or a couch potato
who's laying on a couch and
air-conditioned dents switching the
channel is yelling honey bring in the
popcorn I'm changing the channels and
this is very serious because the Center
for Disease Control says that as many as
a hundred thousand young athletes under
the age of 30 a hundred thousand each
year die suddenly during an event or
training or exercise or immediately
after an event from cardiomyopathy heart
disease and ruptured aneurysm and we
know that cardiomyopathy heart disease
is due to a selenium deficiency and
ruptured aneurysms is due to a copper
deficiency so you can begin to put two
and two together why does a ten year old
died of a ruptured aneurysm well you
sweat out all of this copper and you
can't get copper from curly french fries
and Pepsi just doesn't work
dr. Wallach what about arthritis lorath
Rytas is my favorite disease because
it's easy to fix it's one of the great
myths that the medical profession
perpetuates is that you can't build bone
mass after the age of 50 60 70 years of
age you can only slow down the loss and
the reason why they say that is because
they try to rebuild bone mass using
plain calcium whether it's tums or
calcium citrate or carbonate or
gluconate ER or lactate and your body
will not retain much or any of the
calcium you
supplement with in your bones without
first building new bone matrix you have
to have new bone matrix this is this is
rubbery collagen material that looks
like tender skin and it makes up 25 to
40% of our bone weight forty percent
when you're a child and twenty-five
percent when you're an adult and so it's
absolutely essential if you want to deal
with the wear and tear arthritis
osteoarthritis degenerative arthritis
ankylosing spondylitis effectively you
have to take all 90 essential nutrients
and the best way to do that is with dr.
Wallach cigarettes brightest formula
remember I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and we learned a long time ago
maybe the hundred years ago in
veterinary medicine that we could
actually prevent and reverse maybe even
use the Cure word and animals arthritis
simply by giving the animal the raw
material to develop properly and to
maintain repair the joints and so using
this information that we developed in
animals if you use the same concept for
human beings
I have literally seen tens of thousands
of people over the years who had bone to
bone arthritis they had osteoarthritis
they have degenerative arthritis
ankylosing spondylitis which are
basically a joint form of osteoporosis
it's osteoporosis the joint ends of the
bones and they've tried all kinds of
medication and of course if you take
medication if you take a painkiller if
you take an anti-inflammatory for
arthritis essentially all you're doing
is cutting the wire the red warning
light pain and the joint says don't use
me until you fix me and by taking a
painkiller by taking a anti-inflammatory
which will reduce pain you're allowing
that joint to be used even though it
would have been painful without the drug
and so you're wearing that joint out
faster and faster and faster and to me
it's criminally negligent for someone to
be prescribed a painkiller or an
anti-inflammatory for joint disease
without repairing the joint at the same
time and this is where the pig arthritis
formula really shines and works just
like a charm in human beings so does the
same apply for bone spurs absolutely
bone spurs are a manifestation of
osteoporosis a person will get bone
spurs and calcium deposits when you have
osteoporosis just the opposite of what a
doctor will tell you and you need more
calcium more magnet
you need the bone matrix you need to
college in the glucosamine sulfate the
chondroitin sulfate and those bone spurs
and the calcium deposits will actually
Ryoga textured back down to a normal
bone takes a little while takes four to
six months to pull that off but you can
do it on a regular basis absolutely
cancer seems to be striking everywhere
in our population these days what do we
have that we can help people that are
facing the challenge of cancer it's a
great question back at the turn of the
century 1895 1900 one out of ten
Americans developed cancer right now
it's three out of five and by the year
2050 is projected two out of three
people are going to develop cancer in
America the onset of cancer appears to
be directly related to the amount of of
carcinogens these are toxic waste either
from agriculture or from the industrial
waste that we find in our air and our
food and our water and in the dust
around us and the lack of the ability to
defend against these these carcinogens
in the most common defense mechanism we
have that the one that we have access to
in a very economical way are the
antioxidants like selenium like the
great said extract like the green tea
you're looking at vitamin E vitamin C
beta carotene and avoiding fried foods
and margins and and things we have
control of eating as much organically
grown food as possible and according to
the medical school at the University of
Arizona this came out in JAMA the
Journal American Medical Association
December 25th 1996 I mean we're talking
about a great Christmas gift to the
American people they did a wonderful
study ten years it was a double-blind
study 1,300 people they gave the study
group 250 micrograms which is 1/4 of one
milligram and we're talking an
itsy-bitsy amount of slim they just use
selenium alone didn't change anything
else and by giving these people 250
micrograms 1/4 of a milligram of the
trace mineral selenium they were able to
reduce the risk of esophageal cancer by
71% prostate cancer by 69 percent
greater than two-thirds colon and rectal
cancer by 64 percent almost 2/3
lung cancer was reduced by 48 percent
with the smoked or not and in a parallel
study from the University of California
San Diego 250 micrograms one quarter of
one milligram of selenium the trace
mineral selenium reduce the risk of
breast cancer by 50 to 80% and this same
study showed that if you already have
cancer if you take 250 micrograms of
selenium every day
you will in fact double the natural
history life expectancy of a particular
type of cancer for instance lung cancer
the natural history is about a year
brain cancer is less than a year uterine
ovarian colon breast cancer is 2 to 5
years prostate cancer is 5 to 8 years
well just by taking 250 micrograms of
the trace mineral selenium every day 1/4
of one milligram according to the
University of Arizona's medical school
you can double that life expectancy just
by doing that one thing and so if you
take the other antioxidants and give up
margins and fried foods and sugar and
caffeine and avoid as many of the
agricultural wastes and the toxic waste
from the industry that you can you will
be able to avoid an enormous amount of
cancer and if you already have cancer
doing other things such as taking the
antioxidants and getting on macrobiotic
diets and and so forth you can add many
helpful years to your life you can
certainly have a better quality of life
and many people will extend their lives
in a great way 10 20 30 40 years
obviously there's no way you can look in
somebody's eyes and say you're the one
that's going to live 50 years and so
people just have to do all the right
things and they're going to get the best
that can be gotten from nutrition and
the supplements dr. Wallach I've been a
diabetic for about 30 years what can
what kind of mineral should I take to
help me well first of all are you an
adult onset type 2 diabetic or a
juvenile onset type 1 diabetic juvenile
onset type 1 you are in insulin
dependent because the definition of a
juvenile onset type 1 diabetic is that
you do not make any insulin and so you
will never be able to wean off of
insulin you will always have to take
some insulin but there are - trace
minerals chromium and vanadium that will
make the insulin that you supplement
yourself with very efficient and most
people who are juvenile onset type 1
diabetics are able to redo
the amount of insulin they require to
stabilize our blood sugar by
supplementing with the chromium and
vanadium normally a person learns how to
adjust their insulin by taking their
blood sugar once or twice or three times
a day and so you're taught how to adjust
your insulin intake and just by
following what you've been taught as you
supplement with is plant derived
colloidal and the chelated chromium and
vanadium you will be able to get down to
a new dosage of your insulin and the
value of taking the whole pig arthritis
formula is that there's nothing worse
than paying attention to your blood
sugar levels in your insulin intake and
then dying of a ruptured aneurysm
because you didn't sell a supplement of
copper or developing cancer because you
didn't supplement with selenium so it's
very important even though you're a
diabetic and that is your primary
immediate concern still over the long
haul of being a health conscious person
just out of necessity you're going to
have to supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients and the odds are even though
your juvenile onset type 1 diabetic you
have every honest expectation of living
to be a hundred and symptom-free if you
do everything right yes my question is
on Alzheimer's why is it more prevalent
today that than it was 15 20 years ago
well Ashlee alzheimers disease was a
disease that did not exist forty years
ago
Alice members disease even by another
name could not be found in any medical
dictionary or textbook or taught in any
medical curriculum it only became an
entity in the medical literature in 1979
and today it's apparently the number
four killer of adults United States over
the age of 65 behind cardiovascular
disease cancer diabetes and then comes
alzheimers disease and it appears to me
with no doubt that is due to what I call
a physician cause disease because
doctors have have encouraged people in
fact demanded the people give up
saturated fat and cholesterol and move
towards a cholesterol restricted or even
a cholesterol free diet to get their
blood cholesterol down below 200 and
they have created no less than 25 of
these cholesterol deficiency diseases
and to me Alzheimer's disease is one of
the big ones seventy-five percent of our
brain weight is pure cholesterol it's
called myelin it's this fatty stuff
that insulates each nerve fiber the
brain and spinal cord and we can only
make about 10% of our daily need of
cholesterol the other 90% must come from
the diet and if a person is very very
good at giving up chicken skin and red
meat and dairy and eggs like a doctor
would have them do after about six or
eight or ten years they're not going to
be able to keep up with the maintenance
and repair needs of the cholesterol for
the myelin and the brain and spinal cord
and so you can just expect that the
person is going to develop one or more
of these 25 physician caused diseases
including acquired seizure disorders and
alzheimers disease now the best way to
avoid Alzheimer's disease is to eat a
couple of eggs every morning for
breakfast not cooked in margarine or
fried you want to consume as much as 72
ounces of red meat every month I know
that sounds like a lot but it's just a
quarter-pounder day and you want to
supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients and when you get to the
vitamin E level you want to have at
least two thousand international units
of vitamin E and you want 500 micrograms
of selenium and if you do that even if
you already have Alzheimer's disease you
can expect to have a significant amount
of return of memory great studies done
by the University of California San
Diego in the Salk Institute that says by
taking 2,000 international units of
vitamin E alone even if you have
advanced Alzheimer's disease you can get
a significant amount of memory return i
remodeled homes for families you notice
these little children bouncing off the
walls and went to get for breakfast and
a snack after breakfast and then lunch
again normally has sugar in it is there
any correlation here with a DD
absolutely back to turn-of-the-century
1895 to 1900 Americans reading a half a
pound of sugar per person per year today
it's a hundred and fifty pounds of sugar
per person per year and somebody out
there is eating 300 pounds because I
don't need any and I can tell you that
there's a direct correlation between the
increase in a DD ADHD depression manic
depression bipolar disease and the
increased consumption of sugar and if
you look at it there's five million
American children school-aged children
who are on Ritalin and Prozac and
imipramine and other antidepressants in
school five million
drugged American kids in the preschool
and elementary school simply because
these kids are sensitive to sugar like
many people are sensitive to alcohol
there's good alcoholics who just kind of
go to sleep and they have a couple of
drinks there's a people who get
boisterous and sing loud Irish songs
when they take a couple of drinks and
there's some people who get violent and
very angry and become dangerous to
themselves and other people child abuse
spouse abuse they abuse their neighbor's
road rage is another way of looking at
this life-threatening situations people
actually will gain criminal behavior
sometimes because alcohol acts like a
drug in them same way with sugar some
people when they take in sugar they have
low blood sugar and they just get drowsy
and fall asleep some people when they
take in sugar they get hyperactive and
boisterous and actually a DD ADHD and
then there's some people when they take
in sugar again we'll have road rage
they're very very aggressive and
reactive and can be dangerous to
themselves and their families and other
people in the community and to me it's
criminal for coca-cola machines and
candy machines in school and then wonder
why kids beat up on each other or shoot
each other well in addition to getting
all the sugar out of their life from
sugar frosted flakes and Pepsi's and
Reese's peanut butter cups and candy and
and Pop Tarts and syrup on their aygos
they have to supplement with all 90
essential nutrients even little kids
from the moment they're born to develop
properly this includes their emotions
and repair and maintain themselves and
especially lithium chromium and vanadium
and there's an enormous amount of
research in human beings which show that
lithium deficiency results in
hyperactivity adda ADHD depression manic
depression and criminal behavior and so
it had to do both and you can avoid all
this it's amazing just within days they
will be perfectly normal little kids my
next question is my husband and I are
thinking about starting a family and we
want to know that the nutritional way to
go okay that's a great question people
always ask me when when the children
need to start taking vitamins and
minerals and the answer is when they're
still an egg is when you want to start
them and so we've learned in
animal industry and remember I'm a
veterinarian as well as a physician
we've learned in the animal industry
that we could prevent as much as 98% of
all birth defects even ones that are
thought to be genetic in humans simply
by giving the females especially the
females all known essential nutrients
for that species six months prior to
conception build up that female animal's
body in stores of these essential
nutrients so that the embryo implants in
the uterine wall and develops in an
environment that has optimal amounts
guaranteed optimal amounts of all the
nutrients and you will almost eliminate
the possibility of a congenital birth
defect related to a mineral or vitamin
or amino acid or essential fatty acid
deficiency to give you some idea of how
successful this is according to the
University of California San Francisco
right now in America one out of every 33
human babies in America are born with
some physical or emotional or mental
birth defect one out of 33 in animals
it's only one out of 500,000 if they're
fed these commercial diets that have all
the known nutrients in them and so it's
just very very easy to understand well
if we supplement young women and men who
are in the childbearing years with these
nutrients that we'll be able to
eliminate totally eliminate cleft
palates cleft lip spina bifida eye
defects heart defects hernias various
types
club feet no feet webbed fingers and
toes no fingers and toes muscular
dystrophy Down syndrome cerebral palsy
cystic fibrosis these are all
preventable with proper preconception
nutrition so the earlier that a couple
who wants to have normal healthy
children have a wonderful uncomplicated
pregnancy the earlier you can get on all
90 essential nutrients prior to
conception the better off everybody is
hello dr. Wallach the women in my family
are plagued with hay fever and asthma
and allergies and I don't want to join
those ranks is there a better way
absolutely let's start with asthma it's
the easiest one to deal with asthma is
actually a deficiency of three nutrients
magnesium manganese and the essential
fatty acids and by taking the pig
arthritis formula twice a day you're
going to get the
optimal amounts of the plant-derived
colloidal and icky lated magnesium and
manganese and then by taking the minimum
dealer requirement the nine grams of the
essential fatty acids and those three
nutrients together the magnesium
manganese the essential fatty acids will
allow you to produce what's called
prostaglandins prostaglandins are little
short-lived hormones that last in your
bloodstream 30 seconds 60 seconds and
your body's continuously making them
kind of rapid-fire and when you don't
have those three nutrients you cannot
make the proper prostaglandins to keep
your bronchi and your trachea open and
that's when you develop asthma and it's
very common when people take all 90
essential nutrients including the
magnesium and manganese the essential
fatty acids within weeks or months the
tightness this constant tightness in
their chest is significantly reduced or
maybe even totally relieved the
frequency and the severity of their
asthma attacks is reduced
I would certainly still keep an inhaler
available until you know in case you
have some unexpected emergency kind of
like wearing your seat belt even though
you're on a smooth flight you you're not
going to anticipate sudden turbulence
you need to be prepared for emergencies
but you have every honest expectation of
doing very well then
as far as inhalant allergies from dust
and pollens and seasonal ones from dust
and pollens and maybe constant ones from
danders and cats and dogs and chickens
and feathers and your pillows and that
kind of thing maybe even chemicals that
come out of rugs and for mica and new
cars like formaldehyde other chemicals
you want to get your immune system
working optimally so it can protect you
from these things because most people
are able to tolerate them and what
happens is when your immune system
doesn't have enough nutrition to
function optimally you become a victim
of these things assaulting you all the
time and so what you want to do is
number one take all 90 essential
nutrients or your immune system which
includes your liver and your spleen your
tonsils and your appendix your thymus
your white blood cells which include the
neutrophils and the lymphocytes and the
killer T cells and so forth also you
have eosinophils and basophils you have
neutrophils all of these that white
blood cell
you have albumins and globulin x' which
are the immune proteins you have
antibodies themselves
you have your digestive system your skin
your tears the mucus and your body all
of that requires 90 essential nutrients
to produce this immune system which is
not just your killer T cells it includes
all of these tissues and cells and
organs of your body also if you have
these types of problems you want to get
some of these HEPA filters
it's your workplace in your home when
you sleep you get the ones that you plug
in your car you want to eat as much
organically grown food as possible you
want to drink filtered water you want to
get as much chemicals out of your diet
as possible and the reduce this pressure
on your immune system if you have food
allergies you want to have a five-day
rotation diet you want to take the
enzyme which has the pepsin and the
betaine hydrochloride which will help a
person digest the proteins down into
single amino acid and it's the proteins
and the allergens such as danders and
foods and pollens and dust that cause
the the allergies and even can initiate
an attack of asthma thank you you're
really welcome is it possible that you
can take too much that's a great
question
because people are concerned about
overdosing with the vitamins and
minerals the general answer is that if
you look at the medical profession
according to the Center for Disease
Control Harvard Medical School the US
News and World Report Ralph Nader's
Sidney Wolfe RAND Corporation and many
many other well-respected institutions
they say that doctors kill 150,000 the
300,000 Americans each year in hospitals
alone as a result of medical negligence
doctors injured 1.3 million Americans
each year in hospitals alone as result
of medical negligence and doctors infect
2 million Americans alone in hospitals
as a result of medical negligence for a
total of 3 and a half million casualties
inflicted on the American public each
year in hospitals just as a result of
medical negligence on the other side of
this picture there's not a single person
who's overdosed on vitamins and minerals
and trace minerals to the point where
they have to be hospitalized or anything
bad happen and so when you compare the
safety of vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals are compared with
standard medical procedures it's
enormous
that's why I'm so excited about
nutrition and the pig earth riders for
I'm on the plant-derived colloidal
minerals and that's the direction I go
dr. Wallach my 16 year old daughter has
been diagnosed with fibromyalgia what
can you do for her well it's actually an
easy one we eliminated fibromyalgia and
animals in 1957 and in sheep it was
called stiff lamb disease and also in
sheep and calves and folder baby horses
and chickens and turkeys and any any
other animal that was raised for meat
the disease is caused by a deficiency of
three nutrients the trace mineral
selenium vitamin E and the sulfur
bearing amino acid methionine and
there's two things you have to do to
deal with fibromyalgia number one
eliminate the free radicals and the
trans fatty acids that actually initiate
damage as a muscle and causes scarring
of the muscle tissue which is very
painful even normal muscle movement and
you can understand what they call it
stiff lamb disease if you have
fibromyalgia first of all you eliminate
fried foods such as fried potatoes which
are you know teenagers live on fried
potatoes right so calves eliminate fried
potatoes fried chicken fish shrimp fried
eggs
tempura stir-fry anything fried all
margarine salad dressings with oils in
them have to be eliminated and then
again the Peter thrives problem is
perfect because it has optimal amounts
of the trace mineral selenium and both
the plant derived coal oil and the
chelated form as optimal amounts of
vitamin E and the sulfur bearing amino
acid methionine and it just works like a
charm very quickly within weeks or
months or they feel and they can
recognize some benefit and many people
get significant benefit very quickly dr.
Bai like our baby formulas enough for
babies when they're born unfortunately
not our formulas that we give to dogs
whether it was kind of like sighs that
dog food or the puppy or kitten milk
replacers for puppies and kittens you're
in raised by hand have 40 minerals in
them including the minerals lithium
chromium vanadium and selenium Walsh and
primo laboratory rat pellets contained
28 mils including lithium chromium
vanadium and selenium
there's not a single human milk replacer
on the market on a off the shelf of a
grocery store that has more than 12
none of them contain lithium chromium
vanadium and only two pros soybean
Enfamil have selenium in them and it's
tragic that we give our dogs 40 minerals
in our rats 28 and our kids 12 or less
you can begin to see why we spent 1.2
trillion dollars for health care last
year you begin to see why we only live
to be seventy five point five half of
our genetic potential for longevity
120-140
why are we only ranked 17th and
longevity in 19th and healthfulness
simply because we don't get the basic
raw materials to develop properly and
maintain repair cells from the very
beginning I'll give you a tragic example
sudden infant death syndrome is
something that everybody is familiar
with we eliminated sudden infant death
syndrome in animals back in the 1950s
because farmers can't afford to lose two
or three or five or ten percent of the
baby animals are raising two sudden
infant death syndrome we learned there
was due to a deficiency of the trace
mineral slam causing sudden death and
the most robust the healthiest of the
baby animals in the group or the herd of
the flock and we eliminate it simply by
giving the pregnant mothers selenium and
as soon as the baby is born or hatched
they get selenium and if you look at the
human infant milk replacers on the
market only two of all of them
put selenium in the funnel and so if I
was going to raise a child today on
these infant milk replacers these infant
milk formulas in a can or a bottle or a
box I would pick the two Pro soybean
Enfamil that have selenium in them and
to stack things in favor of the child I
would still get them from the moment
they're born a teaspoon for twenty
pounds of body weight of the pigs right
us-run with twice a day obviously you
may not want to use the orange juice and
a newborn baby because they can develop
allergies to it but I would still give
them the plant derived plural and the
chelated minerals and vitamins and amino
acids and the tragic example of this is
65% this is a known fact sixty-five
percent of all the babies dying of
sudden infant death syndrome in America
are being fed can milk replacers two
thirds are the ones who die of sudden
infant death syndrome are being fed
these canned infant formulas i garantee
a-- they're being fed the ones that
don't have selenium in them and so
absolutely it's important to supplement
these babies from birth because you
can't get everything you need from your
poor food group certainly not out of
these canned formulas thank you